♪
>> Will: THIS IS A STUNNING
STORY DEMOCRATIC CHICAGO MAYOR
LORI LIGHTFOOT CATCHING HEAT
APPARENTLY DECIDING TO ONLY
GRANT INTERVIEWS TO BLACK OR
BROWN JOURNALISTS.
SEVERAL LOCAL CHICAGO REPORTERS
ARE RAISING THE ISSUE AND NOW
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT HERSELF IS
STATING IN A SERIES OF TWEETS,
QUOTE IT'S A SHAME IN 2021 THE
CITY HALL PRESS CORPS IS
OVERWHELMINGLY WHITE IN A CITY
WHERE MORE THAN HALF OF THE CITY
IDENTIFIES AS BLACK, LATINO,
AAPI OR NATIVE AMERICAN?
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION IS
IMPERATIVE ACROSS ALL
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING MEDIA IN
ORDER TO PROGRESS WE MUST
CHANGE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHY I AM BEING
INTENTIONAL ABOUT PRIORITIZING
MEDIA REQUEST.
JOINING US IS WILFRED REILLY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER TO ASK YOU
WHETHER THIS CONSTITUTIONAL OR
IMMORAL?
WHAT IS THIS?
THIS IS SOMETHING WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN.
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S OBVIOUSLY
VERY UNUSUAL FOR A POWERFUL
ELECTED OFFICIAL TO SAY OPENLY
THAT THEY ARE ONLY TAKING MEDIA
INTERVIEWS FROM REPORTERS WITH
ONE RACIAL BACKGROUND.
I MEAN, AND A LOT OF STUFF
THAT'S BEING BILLED AS LIGHT
FOOT IS BILLING THIS AS
ANTI-RACIST ACTUALLY SEEMS VERY
DISTURBINGLY NEO RACIST.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE ARE RETURNING
TO A FOCUS ON RACE ALMOST
EVERYWHERE.
OBVIOUSLY UNUSUAL, CAN'T SEE
THIS AS A GOOD THING.
I ALSO HAVE SOME PRACTICAL
QUESTIONS ALLAH I'M FROM
CHICAGO.
THAT'S A VERY DIVERSE CITY.
WHAT COUNTS AS WHITE?
WOULD AN ARMENIAN GUY?
ARAB AMERICAN PERSON?
ITALIAN CHICAGO GUY?
QUESTIONS REMAIN BUT I'M
SURPRISED BY THE MOVE AND HOPE
SHE MOVES ON FROM IT.
>> Will: REALLY, REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
I LIKE HOW YOU PHRASE THAT THIS
IS NEO RACISM.
I WANT TO G.E.D. TO A SECOND
STORY.
WHERE IS THIS HEADING WILFRED?
WHERE IS THIS TAKING US THIS NEO
RACISM?
IT APPEARS TO BE TAKING US BACK
TO A TIME WHERE WE ARE
INHERENTLY SUPPOSED TO EMBRACE
TRIBES BASED ON OUR VERY SHALLOW
DIFFERENCES AND BASED ON OUR
SKIN COLOR.
IS THAT WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
GOING BACK TO A TIME OF
TRIBALISM?
>> FRANKLY, I THINK A LOT OF
THIS IS GOING TO BE TAKING US TO
COURT.
THE HUGE MAJORITY OF WHITE AND
BLACK AMERICANS ARE FANS OF THAT
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF 1964 WHICH
PROHIBITS ALMOST ALL
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
RACE.
SO I DON'T SEE HOW ONCE THEY ARE
OUT IN THE LIGHT OF DAY THINGS
LIKE THIS FROM WHITE OR FROM
BLACK OR OFFICIALS OF ANY OTHER
COLOR CAN SURVIVE.
I REALLY DON'T.
>> Will: I ACTUALLY MIGHT HAVE
THE PERFECT STORY TO TRANSITION
THEN THAT MIGHT PUT THAT TO A
LITTLE BIT OF A CHALLENGE
WILFRED.
THIS IS FROM GOOGLE DOC, THEY'RE
OFFERING PC ALTERNATIVES FOR
NONINCLUSIVE WORDS.
LET ME GIVE YOU EXAMPLES.
MAILMAN WILL NOW BE MAIL PERSON.
CRAZY BAFFLING, DUMMY VARIABLE
EQUALS PLACE HOLDER VARIABLE.
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY TAKING
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS AND WOKISM
INTO AUTO CORRECT.
INTO GOOGLE DOCS, NO MORE
GENDERED LANGUAGE MAKING
EVERYTHING AS ABSOLUTELY BLAND
GENERIC AND HONESTLY
NON-UNDERSTANDABLE.
COMPLETELY VEGAS AS CAN POSSIBLY
BE.
HERE IS WHAT I WANTED TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THIS IDEA AS YOU SAID IT
WILL ULTIMATELY NOT BE EMBRACED
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT POLLS, THIS
WOKE CRAZINESS, IT'S NOT
POPULAR.
THESE ARE KIND OF PROPOSITIONS
ADOPTED BY SOMETHING LIKE 5% OF
THE POPULATION.
BUT THEY ARE ALSO THE 5% THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY DRIVING PUBLIC
DISCOURSE.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT'S CORRECT.
SUBSTANTIAL OVERLOOK BETWEEN
THAT AND SOMETHING I RECENTLY
READ WHICH IS THAT ONLY 20% OF
THE U.S. POPULATION OR SO IS ON
TWITTER.
ABOUT A TENTH OF THOSE PEOPLE
PRODUCE ALMOST ALL OF THE VIRAL
TWEETS.
THIS IS A NICHE SUBSET OF
SOCIETY.
THE PROBLEM IS IT'S A NICHE
SUBSET EXPOSED IN LARGE PART OF
THE TECHIES, THE ELITE I DON'T
THINK THIS OPTIONAL PACKAGE ARE
GOING TO ADD WOKE AUTO CORRECT
TO MICROSOFT WORD.
ALL I CAN SAY IS I THINK WHEN
THIS REACHES OUT TO THE 47 STATE
BEYOND THE BELTWAY, BOSE ANY
WASH, I LOPE WHAT WE SEE IS.
[LAUGHTER]
INSTEAD OF AN EXTREMELY INTENSE
BACKLASH WHICH SOME IN MY FIELD
WORRY ABOUT.
>> Will: I DON'T KNOW IF
LAUGHTER WILL DO IT BUT THERE
HAS TO BE BACKLASH TO INSANITY
THAT IS SWEEPING THE NATION.
WILFRED, I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
WITH US TONIGHT.
>> YOUR USE OF INSANITY THOUGH
WAS VERY TRIGGERING.